it seemed like yesterday when the Obama
glow appeared it would last forever
[Applause]
[Music]
I love how he milks the applause looks
around well he and Michelle became
global superstars they inspired millions
of Americans and of course the other
global superstars I was at the UN and I
you know I heard our president say that
climate change is the most important
issue facing not only this generation
but all future generations it was
inspiring and it made me feel hopeful
and it made me feel proud to be an
American
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well last night the 20/20 candidates
were singing a different tune with their
sights trained on Joe Biden they decided
to pick off key aspects of the
obama-biden legacy there's this
mythology that somehow all these folks
are in love with their insurance in
America I'm going to go back to Vice
President Biden because your plan does
not cover everyone in America everyone
should have access to health care that
it's a human right
my response is Obama care is working I
asked the vice president point-blank did
he use his power to stop those
deportations open borders is a right
wing talking point and frankly I'm
disappointed that some folks including
some folks on this stage have taken the
bait I found that who we are excuse me
the secretary we sat together in many
meetings I never heard him talk about
any of this when he was the secretary
well this morning the candidates tried
to back off a little of that criticism
but the marker had already been laid
down I miss Obama I miss Obama and I
miss her husband - he is our statesman
and anybody that was executive I too was
an executive for two terms of a city he
ain't perfect
I'm sure Barack Obama was sitting here
and I hope he's sleeping this morning he
would tell you I made some mistakes we
are having an honest conversation about
an administration that was incredible
well nice try Corey bad joke by the way
but you can't have it both ways and even
though Elizabeth Warren and Bernie
Sanders weren't as explicit during that
first debate they feel the same way
because as talented a politician as he
was as attractive a candidate as he was
Barack Obama didn't deliver in critical
areas for the progressives remember when
he said this about NAFTA you scrapped
NAFTA senator Obama or fix it I would
immediately call
the President of Mexico President Canada
to try to amend NAFTA it is absolutely
true that NAFTA was a mistake well he
never did anything about it but Trump
did and what about this golden oldie
never again will the American taxpayer
be held hostage by a bank that is too
big to fail now one problem as noted in
Bloomberg Businessweek two years after
President Barack Obama vowed to
eliminate the danger of financial
institutions that are too big to fail
the nation's largest banks are bigger
than they were before the financial
meltdown thank God for those bailouts
then there was this classic if you like
your doctor you will be able to keep
your doctor period if you like your
health care plan you will be able to
keep your health care plan period no one
will take it away no matter what well we
all saw what happened we all felt it
more doctors are tired higher
out-of-pocket costs higher deductibles
and many Americans receive policy
cancellation notices and then there was
the time that Obama promised America
shovel-ready jobs when he was lobbying
for that 831 billion dollar stimulus
bill and a few years later he said this
shovel-ready was not as shovel ready as
we expected hello there laughing oh it's
a few billion among friends big deal
well from the outset President Obama
promised hope and change
Democrats were mesmerised yet for all
the White House parties the Nobel Prize
the appearance is on Ellen what Obama
delivered was President Donald Trump the
Liberals worst nightmare and ever since
the party has been writhing and venting
bullied by the 2018 midterms but still
vexed by the man who Robert Muller
couldn't take down and now their
finger-pointing and it's ugly but Barack
Obama shouldn't be surprised that the
party is moved to the extremes on issues
like the green New Deal or reparations
he talked a good game but remember when
this went down or how about this when
activists blame police racism and these
tragic deaths the white house fanned the
victimhood narrative a deep distrust
exists between law enforcement and
communities of color some of this is the
result of the legacy of racial
discrimination in this country
now speaking of troubling there was this
punishing line from Obama urging
Hispanics to vote in 2012 if what do you
know sit out the election instead of
saying we're gonna punish our enemies
and I think it's gonna be harder well
that sort of reminds me of this so Obama
shouldn't be surprised no one should be
surprised that the left is really angry
and whipped up Obama himself planted the
seeds of their discontent by the time he
left office this was a CNN Headline take
it in so Democrats should not be
surprised that Obama himself isn't
liberal enough anymore for today's
Democrat party President Obama appeared
to be a dream candidate but now many
feel on the left that they're living in
a nightmare and their rage will likely
dominate the Democratic Party for many
years to come
and that's the angle